- [Instructor] What you see depicted
here is known as a pedigree.
And a pedigree is a way of analyzing
the inheritance patterns
of a trait within a family.
And it can be useful to
understand more about that trait,
maybe to make some insights about
the genetics of that trait, and it's a way
to think about what's happened
in the past in a family,
and then maybe we can help
get some probabilities
or get some understanding of what
might happen in the future.
But let's just break it
down, so we understand
all of the different parts of a pedigree.
So big picture, a circle
represents a female in the family.
And a square represents
a male in the family.
If either the circle or
the square is colored in,
like we see right over here,
or we see right over here,
that means that that
person exhibits the trait.
And the trait of this particular pedigree
is for is the trait of freckles.
And whether or not we're
colored in, that is a phenotype.
That is an observed trait.
You just look at the person and say
do they have freckles or not.
This male right over here
does not have freckles.
This female right over
here does have freckles.
This male right over
But once again, this phenotype,
that's the observed characteristic,
we don't know exactly the
genotype just from this.
Although we might be
able to infer some ideas
about the genotype by seeing
how the phenotype patterns
spread from generation to generation.
But just going back to
understanding the pedigree itself.
When you have a horizontal line
connecting a male and a female,
it's called a marriage line.
And it means that they are coupling up
and they are reproducing.
They don't necessarily, I
guess, have to be married.
It's more that they reproduce.
So this male and this
female have reproduced.
And then this vertical line that goes
from that horizontal line,
that's known as the line of descent.
So it's going from that first generation
to the second generation.
And so all of the people
connected to that vertical line
at the bottom of the vertical line,
these are their children.
All the people who are
directly connected to this.
And this is known as a sibling line.
So, this person, this
person and that person,
they are all brothers and sisters.
You can see that generation one,
they had two daughters, one
of whom exhibited freckles,
and one son, who had freckles.
Now these other people in generation two,
these aren't children
of the first generation.
These are people, you could say,
who are brought into the family.
They either married into the family,
or you could just say they
reproduced with the children.
But that's what's happening
with generation two.
And so you can see, you have another
what's known as a marriage line,
but I guess it could be a
coupling line, a line of descent,
and then they have two
daughters in this case.
So it turns out that freckles
is an autosomal dominant trait.
And I will explain what
that means in a second.
Autosomal
dominant,
dominant trait.
Autosomal means that it
is a trait associated
with one of the non-sex chromosomes.
We have 23 pairs of chromosomes as humans.
One of those pairs determines our sex,
the other ones don't determine our sex.
So this means that freckles is associated
with one of the 22 pairs of chromosomes
that do not determine your sex.
And dominant means that in general
you get two versions of a gene.
One from your mom, and
one from your father.
And each of those versions
of the gene for say
whether or not you have
freckles is known as an allele.
And if a trait is autosomal dominant,
that means that if you
have even just one allele
for that trait, that you are
going to exhibit the trait.
And so, for example, if
the alleles for freckles,
if capital F is you have freckles,
it's dominant, so you write it in capital,
and lowercase F means that
you don't have freckles,
if someone has a genotype
of capital F, capital F,
or capital F, lowercase F,
or, I guess we could say
lowercase F, capital F if we
wanted to think about order.
Which one you're getting
from which parent.
Well then in all of these situations,
they would exhibit the
phenotype of freckles.
And we talk about genotype
and phenotype in other videos.
And of course, the only genotype in which
they would not exhibit freckles
would be having both of
the recessive traits.
So with this out of the
way, what can we infer
about the genotype of this
individual right over here?
And this individual will sometimes be
referred to as individual I-2.
They're in generation one,
and they are individual
two in generation one.
Well, we know that they exhibit freckles.
So we know for sure that since
the phenotype is freckles,
they're in one of these scenarios.
And these two, these two
are frankly equivalent.
So this person, we know
that they're either
capital F, capital F, so that
would be homozygous dominant.
Or they're capital F, lowercase F.
Which are, they are a heterozygote.
Well, let's first think
about the situation
if they are homozygous dominant.
If they are homozygous dominant,
that means to every one of her children,
she would give one of these alleles.
And either of those are dominant.
And so that would mean
if this were the case,
that all of her children would get
at least on dominant allele.
Well, if they all get at
least one dominant allele,
then all of her children
would have freckles.
But we're seeing a situation where
all of her children do not have freckles.
Two of her three children had freckles.
So this cannot be the case.
So this individual right over here
must be heterozygous for freckles.
So they must be capital F, lowercase F.
And what do we know about this
individual right over here,
the person that she coupled up with?
Well, they don't exhibit
the phenotype for freckles.
So they must be lowercase F, lowercase F.
And then from that, you might be able
to intuit a lot more about that.
And we'll do that in
future worked examples.